[Musique]
l'acquis et
qui subissent eux cry for data
dean
niocan décès de la star
enfin le casting
le week end ne l'a pas fait
musique lui
non
[Musique]
bonjour vous venez de découvrir les miss
note les miss notes sont le fruit de ma
créativité
je suis artiste digital touchscreen
artistes
je crée avec mon doigt directement sur
l'écran de mon iphone sans aucune autre
application que les notes et je crée des
portraits de femmes
tout a commencé un soir de janvier 2016
je venais de rentrer mon atelier voilà
et puis un atelier un bel atelier où je
me dis avec des pastels des pigments des
pinceaux sur des grandes toiles en lin
mais voilà plus d'endroit pour peindre
et au même moment je décide d'acquérir
le dernier iphone et le soir je rentre
chez moi
impossible de trouver le sommeil 1h 2h
3h du matin toujours les yeux ouverts
alors je plonge mon bras dans
l'obscurité
j'approche mon iphone et je me dis tiens
quelles sont les dernières
fonctionnalités ma dernière acquisition
alors je regarde je cherche j'ouvre les
notes et je me dis pour tel de nouveau
ses notes
là je clique surgissent 3 crayon une
gomme une règle quelques couleurs
instinctivement je pose mon doigt sur
l'écran et je commence à créer ce qui
sera sans le savoir
ma toute première miss note
alors pourquoi miss note miss parce que
ce sont des femmes note
parce que je les réalise dans
l'application notes vous connaissez
cette application
voilà on peut prendre comme son nom
l'indiqué des notes on y inscrit
quelques mots alors je réalise une miss
notes puis 2-3 je n'ai pas sur les
réseaux sociaux
ça fait le buzz et là je développe une
série de i portrait de femme digitale
innovante les notes multiethnique le
regard frontale l'air affirmé
à votre avis d'où vient la créativité
qu'est ce qui vous pousse à créer alors
quelle a été votre dernière création la
forme qu'elle a prises d'où elle est
venue alors hosking concerne la
créativité ce soir-là a pris la forme je
dois le dire d'un véritable coup de
foudre
une rencontre presque fusionnelle avec
l'écran de cet iphone d'abord sont
touchés vrai lit ce délicat
et puis tapotement des doigts sur
l'écran comme une musique et cette
palette quand même extrêmement réduite
qui vous pousse à vous réinventer la
créativité prend donc naissance dans la
curiosité et souvenez-vous tient compte
est de nouveau ses notes
oui c'est bien le fait d'explorer et
paradoxalement cette créativité proie
aussi naissance dans leur ya chez prise
laisser venir à soi l'instant présent
c'est vrai si vous travaillez la matière
la matière vous répond elle vous fait
créateurs la créativité est donc bien ce
paradoxe qui s'auto nourris entre aller
vers par la curiosité et laisser venir à
soi par le lâcher prise
ce qui permet donc aux miss note de se
révéler sellar révélations et cette
créativité à est un processus infini ses
permanents qui se propage une miss note
amène une deuxième miss notes puis trop
à trente quarante quatre vingts miss
notent aujourd'hui les miss notes sont
rétro projeter sur les monuments
nationaux devant la pyramide du louvre
sur l'arc de triomphe
on peut les voir dans les musées au tête
à londres à côté d'un bonnart et puis
lors de nuits blanches sur des façades
numérique
pourquoi pas vous oui vous aussi laissez
vous surprendre par cet effet de
propagation
parce que tout le monde ici peut créer
quel que soit votre domaine
oui du domaine artistique qui est le
mien jusqu'au domaine scientifique avant
d'être artiste peintre j'étais
comédienne j'ai eu la chance de jouer au
théâtre j'ai tourné
j'ai même été animatrice j'ai chanté et
bien que ce soit la rencontre avec les
notes de l'iphone ou la rencontre avec
un personnage le processus créatif qui
mène à la révélation est identique
d'abord vous faites l'expérience de la
matière vous cumulez de la connaissance
pour l'artiste peintre et formes les
couleurs et puis pour la comédienne est
bien la respiration
la voir le volume le débit accéléré
ralenti la gestuelle le corps dans
l'espace
et puis une fois que vous avez aiguiser
votre instrument et bien comme le
peintre avec sa palette
vous faites preuve de curiosité avec le
texte de l'auteur ont fait plaisir
citons shakespeare roméo et juliette
galoper prestement coursier au pied de
feu ce magnifique
alors là on explore on cherche on
travaille le texte dans tous les sens on
expérimente alors juliette juliette
alors galoper prestement course et au
pied de feu juliette est amoureuse
tam heureuse lui aussi mais voilà les
familles sont pas d'accord c'est pas
possible donc c'est pas possible c'est
grave c'est dramatique galopait
prestement coursier au pied de feu non
ça c'est pas dû être beaucoup plus elle
est beaucoup plus fraîche plus jeune
juliette et plus oui c'est ça c'est plus
volatiles galoper prestement coursier
opté de feu oui elle prit elle supplie
voilà on cherche on expérimente et puis
à un moment donné on lâche prise
il l'a le personnage vient à vous il
s'incarne à travers vous galoper
prestement coursier au pied de feu c'est
l'art révélation encore
et vous alors qu'est ce qui se révèle à
vous j'étais peintre j'étais comédienne
et puis un matin je me rends sur un
tournage
et là tout à fait par hasard je croise
une amie elle me dit qu'un stéphanie tu
donneras pas des cours théâtre c'est
pour ma fille
jusqu'ici moi j'ai surtout joué la
comédie m'écoute
pourquoi pas je veux bien essayer alors
j'ouvre un cours de théâtre première
année expérimentale donc j'accueille
bien sûr des passionnés théâtre et puis
là j'ai quelques timides des anxieux 6
et puis l'année suivante
j'ouvre un cours de préparation mentale
pour les auditions les castings pour
avoir une meilleure gestion du stress en
situation de concours
hélas là une nouvelle matière s'offrent
à moi
les timides le théâtre la gestion du
mental
alors comme dans un petit laboratoire je
commence à faire mes expériences plus
fort oui - vide à on va travailler le
mental est là je m'aperçois qu'avec une
meilleure connaissance physiologique et
mentale le timide pouvait faire preuve
de curiosité avec le monde qui
l'entourent tout en lâchant prise par
rapport au regard des autres ce qui lui
permettait de se révéler révéler sa
personnalité et donc gagner en
affirmation de la créativité digital je
passais à la créativité théâtrale mais
appliqué à l'humain waouh la créativité
comme levier levier de confiance
d'affirmation
alors vous souvenez par effet de
propagation une chose qui en amène une
autre et je commence à construire à
imaginer des exercices qui deviennent
des outils puissants m'en rendre compte
finalement je commence à créer une
méthode et un soir je jouais au théâtre
et dans la salle un directeur de cabinet
d'une entreprise aéronautique vient me
voir il avait vu le spectacle puis me
retrouve à la sortie des artistes qui
m'interpelle madame raphaël je trouve
que vous avez une bonne diction est ce
que vous pouvez faire quelque chose pour
notre dirigeant
il parle vite il voudrait gagner en
impact mois jusqu'ici j'ai accompagné
que des particuliers mais écoutez pour
papa et je veux bien essayer et depuis
la méthode inédite qui venait d'être
créée recommandé aujourd'hui par les
scientifiques a aidé plus de 2500
personnes dans les hôpitaux les centres
de recherche les entreprises et les
universités à se révéler avec des outils
adaptés issus de méthodes créatives on
pouvait ouvrir de très grande porte
je me souviens aymeric aymeric je les
rencontre et à l'inria centre de
recherche dans le numérique et briques
et doctorants il allait bientôt soutenir
sa thèse et ils étaient terrorisés à
l'idée de prendre la parole en public
pour lui c'était un véritable handicap
aymeric c'est le seul participant que
j'ai eu il s'était assis deux profils et
quand son regard croisé mon regard il
tourna la tête
c'était émouvant
aymeric au sein d'un groupe lorsque je
demandais à tout le monde de lever les
bras je vous le font le maximum
d'aymeric donc là on était au maximum
tellement le pauvre il se sentait
ridicule ils n'osaient même pas levé les
bras
aymeric au sein de son laboratoire
personne ne connaissait leçon de savoir
raser les murs et bien aymeric a investi
du travail personnel il a appris à
respirer
il a posé le discours sur la respiration
il a donné des gestes savoie a commencé
à sortir est à l'intérieur a les sorties
et puis la récupérer la confiance et je
le raconte parce que l'histoire est
belle
aymeric a soutenu sa thèse avec les
félicitations du jury pour son aisance à
l'oral c'est une belle histoire est
d'ailleurs aymeric je lui envoyé un
petit texto ya deux jours je lui ai dit
henrik je parlais de toi j'ai la chance
d'être invité au ted est alors je vais
je vais vous montrer la réponse parce
qu'elle est jolie aussi donc j'en ai
profité pour lui demander comment se
passait à ses prises de parole et il m'a
répondu je viens de faire une
présentation un congrès tout le monde
m'a dit que je me débrouille est
vraiment bien à l'oral ça m'a fait super
plaisir
c'est vrai qu'avec des petites portes
avec des vrais outils on peut vraiment
ouvrir le champ des possibles clair
clair manager dans une grande entreprise
alors clair elle avait un double défi
elle devait animer des réunions et faire
des présentations clair elle manque est
tellement de confiance en elle pendant
ces réunions elle prétextait avoir
oublié un dossier elles font c'est aux
toilettes on l'a retrouvé par terre elle
soit super jet d'eau claire elle est
venu à ma rencontre et la toute première
fois que j'ai rencontré elle ne donc
pouvait pas prononcer le mot
présentation elle fondait en larmes
donc je vous raconte le premier
entretien avec elle donc elle est venue
me voir il ya rejoindra fait voilà dans
une semaine donc j'ai une vraie dent de
lion
c'était la première phrase de claire
tibet on va prendre le temps
on va prendre le temps alors racontez
moi clair donc le sujet votre
présentation
l'allemagne rappelle donc
oui bien sûr alors alors le sujet la
présentation dont une heure on n'a pas
dépassé cette phrase avec ce mot là et
puis elle est revenu me voir on a
travaillé elle a appris à mieux
s'occuper d'elle elle a désinvesti le
regard des autres quitte à petit elle a
récupéré en confiance elle a gagné
surtout en concentration est aujourd'hui
clair à une promotion et je ne résiste
pas à vous parler de jérémy jérémy j'ai
rencontré à l'école de la nouvelle
chance phobiques sociale donc jérémy
déscolarisés re scolarisés l'année
dernière et devait passer son bac de
français l'oral blanc il n'a pas pu se
présenter il a passé trois heures à
pleurer dans le bureau la directrice
premier cours avec jérémy aucun son au
sein de sa classe personne n'entendait
un mot en tout cas en groupe de jérémy
est pareil on a fait des exercices
d'abord physique et petit à petit voilà
on a entendu un mot puis deux et après
on a récupéré en résistance on a
surchargé la sensibilité qu'il avait en
la canaliser donc double victoire pour
jérémy il a réussi à se présenter déjà à
l'oral c'était déjà formidable et il a
eu 14 donc les exemples paraissent
extrême timide pathologique dirigeants
mais eux c'est nous et tout le monde
peut progresser à l'oral avec des
techniques basées entre autres un sur
les techniques d'acteurs une bonne
gestion du mental pour tous c'est
possible j'étais quand même loin de me
douter finalement de tout ce que la
créativité allait me permettre de
réaliser
elle m'a permis de soutenir d'aider les
gens à mieux se connaître et toutes ces
femmes digital c'est miss note
finalement elles m'ont poussé à quoi
elles m'ont poussé à m'engager
elles m'ont rendu plus généreuse pour
ces femmes
j'ai donc mis au point des outils pour
qu'elles puissent
être plus assertive développer de
l'autorité naturelle dans la détente à
la fois dans leur domaine professionnel
mais également personnelle c'est miss
note qui m'ont rendu plus généreuse
aujourd'hui c'est miss note soutiennent
l'institut gustave roussy
c'est à dire que simplement pour chaque
miss note que vous souhaitez acquérir
une miss note est offerte à l'institut
dont les bénéfices vont soutenir la
recherche
et puisque les miss notes sont une
grande chaîne de femmes une chaîne sort
aurel bien j'ai le plaisir de mettre en
lumière mais ambassadrice qui sont assia
benziane si vous la voyez apparaître en
haut à gauche
assia formidable elle est membre du g7
elles oeuvrent au quotidien pour la
parité hommes femmes tout jeune a 18 ans
elle a créé des écoles en afrique pour
l'éducation des petites filles à côté
dacia il est alors soyez pilote à
seulement 17 ans elle représente
aujourd'hui l'aviation légère française
vous avez en dessous dacia nathalie
lebas vautier formidable une femme de
coeur d'action nathalie et fondatrice
d'ekyog une marque de mode une des
toutes premières éco responsable une
pionnière
et puis christelle chollet doux et
merveilleuse actrice de music-hall nous
et pour le rire
doué pour l'humour et directrice du
théâtre de la tour eiffel et parce que
les miss notes continuent à se
réinventer et bien je me suis mise en
cuisine j'ai concocté un colline au
chorizo vous voyez là que j'ai
transformée en miss food serait invente
et entre de recettes
il m'arrive de prendre en photo mais
basket que je transforme en me street
la créativité vous apprends sur vous
la créativité vous révèle et la
créativité est partout
moi c'est vrai tout m'inspire un son une
couleur le silence
une voix mais tout le monde peut créer
quel que soit ton domaine que tu sois
musiciens danseuses bricolo artistes
devant ta page blanche derrière tes
fourneaux ton micro scope aller demain
chantons sous la douche coton aux en
expérimentant créant
[Applaudissements]